thank you very much shall we do we
the power of my word will do something
for your subject matter now ladies and
gentlemen first of all I would like to
thank you for including me since I'm in
many ways an outsider to do the issue
here but maybe I could and might
something contribute to how do we deal
with as international community with the
facts of destruction post-conflict
actually hadn't won a sec by the way
this book is just out from her and a
very solid and excellent foundation for
to discuss the Bosnia case which I will
now do actually what why did the
international community react in such a
way as it did in bosnia-herzegovina
where while during the war it was
basically an onlooker there was not much
activity apart from registering the
destruction but the UN forces for
example never took the task upon them to
defend or to protect the cultural sites
in Bosnia and Herzegovina now my task is
to talk about response what has the
international community actually done
and I would like to share with you some
of my own very practical experience
having been the so-called high
representative of the international
community for Bosnia Herzegovina around
the turn of the century 1999 to 2002
actually two crucial years after the war
in in the implementation of the Dayton
Peace Accords as some of you might
recall United States led humanitarian
intervention stopped war in Bosnia
Herzegovina and it was again the United
States who introduced and who led the
peace effort which
then produced to the dayton peace accord
by the way one of the most ambitious
peace treaties around and because the
goal was it still is nothing less than
State Building now they turn is
remarkable for several reasons for do
politically speaking clearly this was
the US unipolar moment where the United
States could indeed dictate what should
happen it was also this kind of feeling
of positive feeling I would say of this
kind of liberal imperialism I can do
mentality when stopping in particular
Wars and asymmetric conflict now the
dayton peace accord with the consent of
the government of bosnia herzegovina and
the neighboring countries croatia and
yugoslavia Densmore yugoslavia of
Milosevic yugoslavia turned wasn't had a
governor intake sort of a semi semi
International Protectorate which was
based on two pillars the military and
civilian but what the military was
extremely bored into the beginning when
it was still lots of tensions around and
nobody was really sure whether it would
not fall back into yet another military
conflict now the civilian part of the bc
fermentation efforts which i was in
charge of was the so-called office of
the High Representative this is an
ad-hoc international organization that
was specifically designed for the
implementation of the data and code in
it is indeed part of the Dayton Accords
as one of the annexes now the so-called
high representative data the top civil
administrator is the final authority in
theater as
the Accords put out with two very
important features the High
Representative as a person this is
directly vested into his position to
impose legislation and to dismiss by
decree public figures which
unfortunately I had to do more than 100
times now the stated goal of the date
and record was to reverse the impact of
ethnic cleansing to preserve the unity
of the state and to bring back in
particular the more than 2 million
refugees and idps internally displaced
persons of course the priorities at the
beginning were far more directed towards
the humanitarian issues that this was
really a fight about the sheer survivor
and also to create a safe and secure
environment both for the population as
well as for the international community
which went there at the beginning as
around 60,000 military and several
hundred ten several thousand civilians
working there both diplomats
government's international the national
officials as well as NGOs now as I've
already mentioned the centerpiece of the
dead record really is to bring back the
expelled population as i said the
population of all together barely four
million and more than fifty percent were
expelled and the issue of course was how
how do we actually counter the ethnic
cleansing the terrible word for
something and what what actually spells
success and success in bringing back
refugees and idps was really do can they
go back into territories into areas
where they then where they are part of
the minority of either serbs croats or
Bosniaks now in two thousand and this is
quite interesting
I was yet as I said between 99 and 2000
to there was a breakthrough in in
minority of returns even Human Rights
Watch which is usually not very friendly
with international organizations
speaking of the breakthrough and very
positive terms about the work that we
are doing there it was a coincidence
that also in the year 2000 actually the
UNESCO led efforts to to bring to deal
with the cultural devastation there came
to an end it was handed over to the
local government now one thing is
important to mention and this is that
actually this is the first piece tricky
and there are not many others I used to
negotiate han bui agreement for for
bosnia for kosovo and there the the
cultural aspect is mentioned but not
that as prominently as in the case of
bosnia-herzegovina where the annex 8
actually created a commission to
preserve national monuments and x8 was
in the first couple of years of a rather
limited success and unesco guidance
there was a list of monuments that was
created but there was no formal process
to speak of how to go about her but then
the year 2000 when when more and more
refugees found a way back into the
original villages and small towns
usually that they start at the sort of
her i would say interplay between the
two dayton provisions this is an x 7
refugee return in one hand and nx8 as
the commission to preserve natural
monuments on the other hand and clearly
it was in that was pointed out in Helens
presentation already it was mostly
muslim sacred buildings mosque that were
destroyed in this in a very systematic
way because the idea on the syrup side
was really to create what they what he
referred to as a greater serbia project
now we had the we on the other hand
international community we had to
consider in order to make the returns
sustainable that rehabilitation the
reconstruction was very important this
is the other side it was used to reverse
the ethnic cleansing so to speak the
physically cleansing if you if you may
in order to make it as sustainable which
of course includes to sort of recreate
as said a sense of belonging also safety
security is very much attached to this
in short to stabilize those those
communities there who were shaken so
thoroughly and of course it was is oil
it was also thought to be some sort of
adventure reconciliation and
truth-finding exercise which will have
to come under way eventually there we
also need to clearly deal with a
systematic destruction of cultural
monuments now the question of course is
also that the interesting thing that
happened is that with the increasing
returns and more and more efforts which
were frustrated in the first couple of
years to rebuild this mosque this led to
server violent clashes and incidents
particularly in serb dominated areas
like two occasions in bond a look at the
capital of the serb dominated and aunt
Edie republika srpska wear a cone
a stone laying ceremony was ambushed by
extremists and hooligans and also
another one in now that serve dominated
ton of traveling not far away from from
Dubrovnik if you know where Dubrovnik is
a cravat and one hour's drive but inside
of Bosnia and Herzegovina not in Croatia
where Doberman agates now this made it
necessary to thoroughly reconsider
actually how to move forward in the
implementation of this nh-8 and the
Commission riverton my office decided on
taking a wholly new approach which which
was basically based or two on two
elements through a two-track approach if
you may first and foremost to harmonize
legislation in the country at the
different layers of governance that
existed there created by the data
network far to overcome volute in far
too complex but it's just a fact and
this legislation basically served to to
hinder and to obstruct any meaningful
action they are not just in the cultural
field of course in many other fields as
well and secondly to to reconstitute
this commission for the cultural
monuments at the time and when I when in
preparing for this for is small in short
lecture window them over the papers from
that time and there I reread a letter
with which I wrote to the UNESCO
Director General at the time where I
complained about the Byzantine jungle of
non-uniform laws concerning construction
permit application it's kind of a
hyperbolic the language but it also
expresses the frustration that we were
confronted with now what hold up was a
drawn-out negotiation process working
groups were set in drafting
drafting sessions took place and I had
basically to mediate between local
actors international community the
security aspect for example the
stabilization force there were nato-led
was not very happy about those violent
incidents because they were in charge of
safe and secure environment now thanks
to the powers invested in me and this
needs to be underlined here as high
representative eventually amended the
laws and I imposed in a republic of
srpska the whole legislation because the
National Assembly there simply would not
have done its job now at the same time
and let me just mention those few
examples which took place in Mille
taneously and that was where my decision
on the location of the cemetery for this
reps rabbinate victims as well as the
missing persons initiative DNA based
identification process that took place
and we also very much supported the ICP
why do you miss Olivia tribunal to
include cultural genocide in it said on
the other hand they are also business
activities where one who was trying to
so to speak disrupt this cultural
reconstructions of course this all was
intended to foster normalization and to
support the community building efforts
now 15 years on bosnia-herzegovina is
still very much divided society I'm
afraid that it's on it downward spiral
and but there are also some positive
things first of all the the Commission
the annex 8 Commission is arguable dear
only success story when it comes to the
state level institutions in
bosnia-herzegovina we know that all the
so-called national museums and galleries
are closed there is no money for this
but above all there is no common
narrative for a state of
bosnia-herzegovina maybe we will speak
later on about the lessons because there
are some
that it could be drawn from Bosnia
Herzegovina thank you so much